so we're learning more now about the sad
toll of the coronal lockdowns in this
country according to hope i don't know
we could get another round of lockdowns
these for a crisis that's every bit as
bad as the chronovirus may be worse that
crisis of course
says joe biden is climate change today
i'm
pleased to announce a team that will
lead my administration's ambitious plan
to address the existential threat of our
time
climate change folks we're in a crisis
just like we need to be a unified nation
in response to covert 19
we need a unified national response to
climate change
and from this crisis from these crises i
should say
we need to seize the opportunity to
build back and build back better
than we were before a unified
national response it's involuntary
that's the one thing we know
what does it mean we're learning that a
world health organization
staffers written a report saying that a
climate lockdown
could be called fortuna covered lockdown
a climate lockdown
mark morano is an author who has written
a lot about climate change he founded
climate depot he joins us tonight mark
thanks so much for coming on
a climate lockdown now i would laugh
this off the table except we all just
lived through the last
18 months so we know that anything is
possible what does this mean exactly
well you know in my book green fraud i
detail two chapters on this tucker this
is the climate activists were first of
all
jealous when the coveted lockdowns
happened they were beside themselves
saying
how is this happening everyone from
greta thunberg to john kerry un
officials
and then they started saying we need to
follow this
if we can shut down for a virus we can
shut down for climate
and that's what we're seeing there's
even academics in australia proposing
adding climate change to death
certificates and bill gates has said the
death toll will be greater so
they're following every step of the way
and it's not just you know a professor
here or someone in academia we have a
major uk report coming out we have an
international agency report that came
out
calling for essentially the same type of
lockdowns
everything from restrictions on your
thermostat to restrictions of moving
uh you know you can only fly in a
climate emergency when it's quote
morally justifiable you know kind of
like a lockdown you have to justify
going to the store for essential
services
they're going after freedom of movement
they're going after private car
ownership
they're going after everything it means
to be a free person and turning it over
to the administrative state
would this include shutting down the
iphone factories in china
would china and india participate in
this climate lockdown or is it kind of
you first america
well you know as we know the lockdowns
had never been proposed we felt like
lemmings following the
the chinese communist party in terms of
them recommending lockdowns the world
health organization went after it the
world health organization employees are
now recommending these climate lockdowns
the one person countries that won't be
affected is china as
you say as we're sitting home binge
watching netflix we're not going to be
able to have the freedoms we used to
have
in the uk they proposed co2 ration cards
that the government
or employers would monitor your co2
levels you know your energy use your
travel the type of car you drive
if you exceed a level you pay penalties
if you're under you get credits
this is the world a co2 budget for every
man woman and child on the planet has
been proposed
by a german climate advisor this is our
this is what we're looking at
you know i talked to a german who talked
about east germany used to have these
kind of restrictions
in east germany before you could leave
the country but we're talking about
proposing these now
on americans within the country and we
had this of course with covert they were
talking about bans on interstate travel
at one point
a national ban some of biden's advisors
so anything is possible chuck schumer
is urging biden to declare a national
climate emergency
just like a blue state governor he could
have emergency powers
i feel such a deep shame that americans
complied with what we've just been
through and i hope that
they will not comply with this i really
do mark thanks so much for coming on
that
sure thank you tucker hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else